هناك بعض المعلومات الجديدة المتعلقة بفصيلة الدم وفيروس كوفيدا نريد أن نشير إلى أن المرضى الذين لديهم فصيلة دم من نوع o أو b يكونون أقل عرضة للإصابة بالفيروس أو للإصابة بأعراض شديدة إذا فعلوا ما مدى موثوقية الأدلة التي تشير إلى هذا وماذا هل يعني ذلك بالنسبة للعلاج الذي تعرفه ، أعتقد أن هذا سينتهي به الأمر إلى أن يصبح سؤالًا جيدًا في السنوات القليلة المقبلة مع جائحة 2020 في نهاية المطاف ، لا يوجد شيء يمكننا القيام به لتغيير فصيلة دمنا ، أعتقد أنه من المثير للاهتمام معرفة أنه إذا كان لديك فصيلة الدم التي قلتها من البقاء في وحدة العناية المركزة والحصول على هذا قد يكون لديك أيضًا خطر أقل للإصابة بالطمع 19. إذا نظرت إلى الجينات الخاصة بنوع فصيلة الدم لديك ، فأنت تحصل عليه مباشرة من والديك. البروتينات الموجودة على سطح خلايا الدم الحمراء هذه والتي تحدد فصيلة الدم لديك بشكل جيد ، فلن تكون قادرًا على تغيير فصيلة دمك وليس الأمر كما لو كان بإمكاني إخبار المرضى المصابين بالدم  قم
بخلع قناعك ويمكنك الذهاب إلى
الحانات والعيش بحرية في
نهاية المطاف ، بغض النظر عن نوع فصيلة الدم
لديك ،
عليك الانتباه إلى تدابير السلامة ،
فقد بدأ انتشار فيروس كورونا في الشتاء
وفقًا لنمذجة مؤثرة
مجموعة في جامعة
واشنطن
والتي تتوقع الآن أن حوالي 160.000
أمريكي قد يموتون
بحلول شهر فبراير ، تتجه أول 32 ولاية
في الإبلاغ عن حالات جديدة ، حيث كان هناك أكثر
من 70000 حالة جديدة في جميع أنحاء البلاد
يوم الخميس
وهو أعلى عدد يومي في الأشهر 12
ولاية لديها  لقد رأينا للتو أعلى
متوسطات على الإطلاق لسبعة أيام للحالات الجديدة
، لقد سئم الناس للتو
من شهور من العمل الجماعي والتباعد الاجتماعي ،
لقد تخلوا عن
حذرهم وللأسف لم ينته الفيروس التاجي
معنا حتى الآن حتى لو انتهينا من ذلك.
الفيروس التاجي ولذا فنحن بحاجة فعلاً
إلى مضاعفة
ارتداء قناع التدابير الأساسية هو
رقم واحد رقم اثنين وثلاثة
في الواقع مجموعة النمذجة نفسها في
الكون  قال رئيس المعاهد الوطنية للصحة إنه
إذا كان 95 في المائة من الأمريكيين يرتدون أقنعة في
الأماكن العامة ،
فيمكن إنقاذ حياة أكثر من 100000 شخص
خلال شهر
فبراير في غضون ذلك ، قال رئيس
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة
إن اللقاح لن يكون الحل السحري
إذا لم يحصل عليه عدد كافٍ من الناس
لقد كنت أتحدث بتفاؤل شديد
حول الكيفية التي من المحتمل أن نحصل فيها على
لقاح بحلول نهاية العام ،
ولكن إذا كان 50 من الأمريكيين فقط
مهتمين بتناوله ، فلن نصل أبدًا إلى
هذه النقطة من المناعة عبر
السكان حيث
Covet 19 يذهب بعيدًا ، قد يكون هنا لسنوات
في ثلاث مناطق ساخنة لفيروس كورونا في
الولايات المتحدة.نهج مختلفة تمامًا لإخفاء
ارتداء عمدة نيو أورلينز تقول إن أي شخص لا
يرتدي قناعًا في مدينتها
يمكنه الحصول على تذكرة 500 ولكن في جنوب
داكوتا ، تويت الحاكم  أنه
لا ينبغي للحكومة أن
تفرض ارتداء القناع ، اقتبس من أولئك الذين
لا يريدون ارتداء قناع لا ينبغي أن
يخجلوا من ذلك ، فهي تقول
إننا بحاجة إلى احترام قرارات بعضنا البعض
وفي كولورادو ،
قام قاض فيدرالي  مع كنيستين
رفعتا دعوى قضائية ضد
القاضي حكمًا بأن الكنائس لا
تضطر إلى الحد من سعتها
الداخلية ولا يتعين عليها مطالبة أبناء
الأبرشية بارتداء أقنعة ، فهذا يتعارض تمامًا مع
قواعد كولورادو الـ 19 التي
سنعبدها معًا ، وسيكون لدينا
غناء جماعي
و  يمكننا القيام بذلك دون تدخل
الحكومة ،
أجد أنه من
المربك
إلى حد ما على حد علمي أنه لا يوجد
دين في
العالم لا يضع حياة الإنسان على أنها
الأولوية الأولى للقيمة الأولى
ولكن الدجاج نفسه ،
إنه أمر
مقزز  الشيء المفضل هو القهوة التي أشربها
عدة مرات في اليوم
عندما أشم رائحتها الآن رائحتها
مثل الإطارات المحترقة
والثوم هنا عندما أشم هذه الرائحة
وكأنها قمامة ، لقد
تحولت من بدون رائحة إلى ربما
أسبوعين من ثلاثة أسابيع
معتدلة  تعود الرائحة ثم انتقلت الرائحة
من
العودة تدريجيًا
مثل ببطء معتدل إلى مجرد
اتخاذ منعطف سيئ للغاية
تمر به ، ربما يكون مجرد
يوم غريب أماه  إذا كان هناك شيء فاسد ،
فربما تكون القهوة فاسدة ،
ربما تعرف ، ثم تدرك
أنه ليس كما تعلم ،
اعتقدت أن هناك شيئًا ما يحدث
في منزلي ، اعتقدت حقًا أن شيئًا ما
مات في مرآبي
، لقد مر حوالي ثلاثة أسابيع منذ أن
شممت الرائحة
تلك الرائحة البلاستيكية المحترقة عندما آكل
أو أستحم ، أغسل أسناني بشكل طبيعي
عندما تكون مريضًا وحدث شيء خاطئ ، تذهب
إلى
الطبيب يعطيك راحة من المعرفة
،
هذا هو العلاج الذي تعرفه ولكنه
ليس مقطوعًا حقًا  جاف في هذا الموقف ،
إنه غير معروف وأعتقد أن هذا هو
الجزء المزعج الذي
أعتقد أن الجزء الأصعب فيه هو عدم
معرفة كيفية شرحه للناس ،
ويبدو الأمر وكأنه أصبح
جزءًا كبيرًا من حياتي لأنه
شيء أنا "  أتعامل مع
كل يوم كان لدي الكثير من القلق
بشأن إصابتي بالفيروس
وعدم معرفة الآثار التي يمكن أن تحدثها
على حياتي من الآن فصاعدًا وعندما لا زلت
أعاني من آثار جانبية باقية بعد سبعة
أشهر ثمانية أشهر  في وقت لاحق من عندما تم
تشخيصي بعد
ذلك وكأنه يقلقني حقًا